philippe le ray bonsoir est le président
de l'antenne de versailles et de sa
région de l'ufc que choisir est donc un
guide que vous avez édité qu'il est
possible de se procurer via votre site
internet qu'on peut consulter en ligne
pour donner quelques conseils des
conseils sur tous les aspects ça va de
l'achat du sapin à l'achat sur les
marchés de noël par exemple aujourd'hui
véritablement c'était indispensable de
faire ce guide pour les consommateurs
ils sont plus en plus nombreux à venir
vous voir à cette période de l'année
oui ils sont de plus en plus nombreux
parce que comme vous le savez bon c'est
une période d'achats plus importante
pour les ménages
il faut savoir qu'en moyenne dans chaque
famille consomme en moyenne 3 146 euros
et donc plus d'achats plus de risques de
se tromper plus de risques de se faire
arnaquer d'où d'un besoin de conseil
auprès du fc que choisir car ça va sur
tous les registres je le disais tout à
l'heure parmi les difficultés
rencontrées plus souvent par les
consommateurs il ya ces questions des
étrennes les étrennes que l'on donne en
fin d'année aux postiers par exemple de
plus en plus souvent par exemple de faux
pompier de faux postiers se présente
pour recueillir des est raide chaque
année il ya toujours des arnaques
c'est dans ce domaine lorsque tu as un
faux positif au montpied f éboueurs
également comment on fait pour se
prémunir de sa comment on fait lorsqu'on
est chez soi et qu'on sonne à la porte
et que finalement on n'ose pas dire non
parce qu'on voit un pompier a posté qui
vient la maison on n'a pas forcément le
doute en fait c'est vrai bon en cas de
doute qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
premièrement demander une carte
d'identité professionnelle
en principe ces personnes là dehors une
carte d'identité professionnelle et donc
doivent être en mesure de le présenter
si ce n'est pas le cas parce qu'il ya
aussi des fausses cartes d'identité donc
un code de doute refusé et demander à la
personne de repasser dans les jours deux
jours trois jours et si c'est quelqu'un
qui fait normal qui ne repassera pas
aller aussi les marchés noël ça aussi on
peut s'y intéresser sur les marchés de
noël qui sont de plus en plus nombreux
forcément il ya de plus en plus d'
arnaque
par exemple les appellation trompeuse un
vin chaud toujours à consommer avec
modération vous le savez mais si on veut
prendre un vin chaud recettes maison et
qu'on s'aperçoit que finalement c'était
plutôt des briques qui sont dans
l'arrière boutique on peut déposer un
recours
fleury qui les tromperies bien sûr la
race menacée le code du commerce qu'il
peut respecter le code de la
consommation donc dans ces cas là bas
soit de saisir au niveau des pieds que
choisir ou saisir également
départementale de la protection des
populations mais assez compliqué parce
qu'un marché de noël est là de manière
très éphémère ils sont là pendant deux
jours voir déployer une journée est ce
que véritablement le consommateur à un
recours là-dessus même blessure qui peut
le signaler et sierra derrière ce qui se
passe en sait déjà c'est que l'année
prochaine ce gouvernement ne reviendra
par déjà ça c'est la première chose
c'est des projets inutiles
voilà un qui généralement vous savez
aussi que la commune est responsable
aussi de sur les marchés de la paix de
la police des marchés
donc la commune interviendra sinon cela
alors juste aussi une autre précision
parce que ça c'est important toutes les
mentions que vous pouvez voir sur les
différents marchés de noël sont
réglementées que ce soit bio campagne
artisanale là aussi il ya une loi qui
s'applique on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
voilà un peu n'importe quoi c'est à dire
que un marché de noël privilégie
notamment les produits artisanaux et des
produits locaux
donc dès l'instant où l'on constate que
des produits viennent de loin très loin
il peut venir de très loin à ce moment
là n'ont rien à faire sur un marché de
noël et elle a aussi donc il faut le
signaler et tous les conseils pour le
signal et toutes les mesures de
précaution à prendre aussi vous les
retrouvez donc dans le guide édité par
l'ufc à retrouver sur le site internet
qui s'est affichée tout à l'heure il
serait affichera encore au cours de cet
entretien
on va juste faire une petite pause vous
demander tout simplement être vous
vigilants aux périodes de en période de
noël faites vous attention à ce que vous
dépensez vos réponses à tout à fait j'ai
un budget à respecter donc aussi bien
pour mes courses que pour noël tranché
extrêmement attention coup
on est en pleine crise économique et on
en est victime comme tout le monde et
donc on fait très attention à ce qu'on
achète et budgets sont réduits de
manière assez importante
erasteel cette année oui mais attention
aux prix et puis dans l'occurrence cette
année j'ai fait des cadeaux un peu
exceptionnel on va dire je veux faire un
ipad à mon fils et puis une ds3 ou aux
plus jeunes
c'est ce n'est pas près les même prix
partout et on a fait plus attention aux
professionnels pour mme promotionnels
sur les offres de jeux qui était vendu
avec voilà voir les étiquettes dans
plusieurs magasins pour voir ce qui est
le plus intéressant c'est toujours
bénéfique
c'est plus un coup de coeur un coup de
coeur
typiquement sur les objets sur les
jouets d'enfants
c'est un compromis entre entre le coup
de coeur et le prix quand même
les gens font surtout attention aux prix
qu'ils sont pratiqués font pas forcément
attention sur la provenance sur les
normes c'est par exemple les choses
comme ça oui vous avez raison
donc bon tout dépend si le l'objet ou le
joué par exemple est acheté auprès d'un
commerçant
oui s'il d'acheter en ligne avec de plus
en plus il ya des achats en ligne donc
trois sont plus pour être encore plus
vigilant bien vérifier par exemple ce
que je viens pendant le reportage ci la
nation c'est eux c'est à dire la
conformité à la réglementation
européenne est respectée
et puis pour la sécurité vérifier si les
objets sur de bonnes qualités citées pas
des risques de dégradation fenal si
l'objet est sérieux pour cela donc des
possibles est simple aller sur les
comparateurs de prix au niveau de ces
quelques choisir nous en avons plusieurs
et puis également vérifier donc sur les
forums des acheteurs donc quelles sont
les choses à éviter quelques conseils
pour le père noël au moment de se
procurer les jouets pour les enfants
il ya des abus sur les coûts justement
période de noël des coûts des prix qui
sont gonflés sur cette arrivée
bon là aussi aller sur les comparateurs
et vérifiez donc si des crises ou
d'exagérer on continue à regarder un
petit peu les différentes arnaques sur
lesquels il faut être plutôt vigilant on
peut évoquer aussi les restaurateurs
alors là aussi c'est très important
parce qu'il ya toujours des menus de
fêtes qui sont proposés et on se trouve
forcément tout et n'importe quoi j'ai
envie de dire oui
alors on m'a déjà vu désormais un cadre
dans le passé par exemple des des offres
pour rêver
dans un château et puis le 31 décembre
on se présente dans le château et il ya
personne le château fermé bon bah c'est
encore plus compliqué mais au-delà de
cela bon bien vérifier l'affichage des
prix et des menus il dit avoir un double
affichage à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
du restaurant également sur la qualité
sur la cuisine industrielle qu'on trouve
de plus en plus souvent alors selon le
site sudouest environ 70 % des
établissements français seraient
soupçonnés la d'affiché du prêt à
consommer et donc pas précisé forcément
la bonne origine et la bonne fabrication
des produits qui sont vendus
oui c'est vrai que bon si on marque plat
du jour ou produits frais normalement ça
fait du crochet et donc toutes les
arnaques que vous retrouvez tout au long
de l'année forcément se retrouve aussi
au moment de noël avec une forcément
beaucoup plus d'attention à avoir sur
les sites internet à environ 9 milliards
sera dépensé 9 milliards d'euros par les
français via les achats en ligne on
imagine plus il ya d'achat en ligne
publie à d'abus et là aussi il ya
toujours des recours et les associations
de consommateurs y veille
oui tout à fait beaucoup de beaucoup de
saisie vous êtes saisis de beaucoup de
dossiers sur quelle période c'est après
les fêtes justement où déjà dès à
présent c'est plutôt après les fêtes
j'étouffe ou plutôt pour les faits alors
que là vous me reposer un peu et vous
vous attendez à ce que ce soit compliqué
ensuite merci philippe le hdmi sur le
plateau président de l'ufc que choisir
de versailles et sa région le guide à
retrouver sur le site internet on passe
au rappel des titres les principaux
sujets abordés en ce 17 décembre
les villes ont l'obligation avant le 31
décembre de se regrouper entre elles un
schéma de coopération intercommunale a
été arrêté il fixe les périmètres de ces
nouvelles communautés d'agglomération
pas de grandes modifications pour
l'instant la fête des lumières où anouk
à cette fête juive a été célébré comme
tous les ans à montigny le bretonneux en
présence cette année de samuel sandler
le rabbin de versailles est durement
touchée par la tuerie de toulouse il ya
quelques mois car dans son fils et ses
deux petits enfants
en football américain des templiers
d'elancourt ne reprendront leur saison
qu'à la mi-février l'heure est aux
matches amicaux à la préparation pour
les joueurs de saint quentin qui
évoluent dans le champ
jeune acolyte la plus haute division et
ont volé en régionale une masculine les
joueurs de montigny affrontés dans leur
gymnase l'équipe leader du championnat
plaisir logiquement lésigny montant se
sont inclinées 3 sets à 1
je vous retrouve mardi dès 18h en direct
et puis à 19 heures pour la première
rediffusion nouvelle édition du 7 8 de
cette suite se présente jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine et la semaine prochaine
durant les fêtes des éditions spéciales
pour faire le point sur 2012 évoqué
aussi les gros dossiers de 2013 je vous
retrouve demain bonne soirée